There are some special right triangles that can help us problem solve even more
quickly than using the Pythagorean Theorem. If you were able to solve the last
problem without using the Pythagorean Theorem, then great work. If you didn't,
I would go back and check that solution, see how we can do it. For the last
problem, we could actually use this special ratio 3 to 4 to 5 to find a missing
side length. If the side lengths are on the ratio of 3 to 4 to 5, then any
multiple of that would also be a right triangle. So, if I multiplied each of
these by 2, I could also have a 6, 8, 10 right triangle. We know this is a
right triangle since 6 squared is 36, 8 squared is 64, and 10 squared is 100. A
squared plus b squared equals c squared. So multiplying through by any number
for this ratio would give us a right triangle. We could multiply through by 3
to get a different right triangle. In fact, that triangle would be a 9-12-15
right triangle. So by knowing a special right triangle, we can generate an
infinite amount of larger right triangles. That's why this ratio is so
important. In fact, it's called a Pythagorean Triple. There are a couple of
Pythagorean Triples that appear often enough that it's helpful to know these.
If you're able to quickly recognize these, then you can easily find missing
side links. For example if we had this right triangle that had a leg of 35. And
a hypotenuse of 125 units. What would be this missing leg? Now you could use a
pythagorean theorem to solve for this missing leg. But I really want you to
think about this in terms of ratios. Which of these ratios can help you find
this missing leg. Choose the one that you think it corresponds to and then fill
in the missing number based on the multiplier. Good luck.